Ethiopian state TV says there are no
survivors in the crash of an Ethiopian
Airlines Boeing 747 max traveling from
Addis Ababa to Nairobi 157 people were
on board the plane was delivered to the
airline just four months ago Ethiopian
Prime Minister Abbey Achmed tweeted news
of the incident sending condolences to
the families of the passengers the jet
lost contact with air traffic control
just minutes after taking off the
tracking web site flightradar24 says the
plane had an unstable vertical speed
Kenya's Transport Secretary has just
been giving a press conference on the
crash let's listen to what he had to say
to Japan Airlines this morning
you will be aware of that the incident
is to make that game that beat when the
flight took off for Polly
and six minutes little
it got lost in council run civilians
entirely 149 passengers aboard
but our parts in the sky authorities we
are waiting for my position
on this
but in the meeting we have you seated
group in airports
magis responses basically take care
or relatives and prints
we'll be affected
what we see the passengers upon arrival
to know
the freight was expected to arrive in
Nairobi at about 10:30
it is teach what we've done is to
establish
imagine Sanders won the water Cortana 20
whereby we shall be meeting different
threats to meet the passages for tonight
upon arrival t1d
those ranches and friends we directed to
the second multiple Center 24 points
which is within the facility
the purpose of this centers is to
provide
[Music]
relatives will call meeters and greeters
with information
as much as we hoped
the same time probate them in the
tournament
because until we look what is happened
our correspondent Melanie credible joins
us now from Nairobi where the flight was
headed Melanie what's the latest on the
crash what more can you tell us Rebecca
well up until just now we were told that
the rescue and search operations were
still under way 260 kilometers south of
Addis Ababa but of course we have now
learned that there are no survivors
among the passengers from 33 countries
there are still a lot of information
which is missing which is still unclear
we do know that the flight left at 880
388 this morning and apparently crashed
just six minutes after takeoff we are
hearing some details now about what
could of course the crash but we still
do not have the full picture as soon as
we have it we will of course update you
on that give us a bit more information
on the plane that went down and we can
where the boeing 737 which can carry up
to 210 passengers was just purchased by
the airline just four months ago it was
basically brand-new it is considered to
be a safe plane although there has been
another Boeing 737 which crashed in
Indonesia last year but when we talk
about Ethiopian Airlines they are
state-owned they also considered to be a
very very safe airline wildly respected
together with Kenyan Airlines the
islands most used here in the region
although we also do have to say in 2010
there was another incident when a plane
of Ethiopian Airlines did crash after
had left Beirut and 90 people died back
then well people have been gathering at
Nairobi Airport as we said that there
was the flights destination what's tell
us a bit more about the scene there well
reactions and condolences are just
starting to pour in there are a lot of
people who are just learning about the
incidents as we speak many people are
now at nairobi airport and many are
hoping to get more information on what
has happened
European airlines has tweeted out
emergency contacts so that families can
get in touch with them and when you look
at other people all across the country
they ask using social media not to reach
out as well for example hurricane yata
the president he has been saying my
prayers go out to all the families and
associates of those on board and we're
just expecting one more condolences to
be extended and to be pouring in
throughout the day JW's Melanie credible
in Nairobi many thanks